mientras estaba haciendo mi tesis de
doctorado tuve la oportunidad de volver
a chile como profesor visitante a una
universidad el primer día que llegué me
presentaron a mis colegas me mostraron
mi oficina y me dijeron la secretaria te
va a dar el resto de los detalles
al momento de preguntar dónde estaba el
baño la secretaria me dijo ven sígueme y
tomó un puñado de llaves
llegamos a un lugar donde había dos
puertas y las secretarias se quedó
perpleja
y me dijo no sé qué llave darte la
primera puerta decía profesores la
segunda decía secretarias
después de pesar un rato la señora me
dijo mejor te doy la llave de las
secretarias porque la llave de los
profesores lo usan solo hombres
cifras recientes publicadas por las
naciones unidas indican que de los
graduados de licenciaturas
universitarias en todas las disciplinas
las mujeres somos la mayoría el 53 por
ciento sin embargo si pasamos a los
graduados de doctorados encontraremos
que solamente el 43% son mujeres y aquí
viene una cifra bastante difícil las
naciones unidas estima que de todos los
investigadores del planeta solamente el
28 por ciento menos de un tercio son
mujeres
este fenómeno de porcentajes
decrecientes a lo largo de la carrera
profesional está estudiado y se denomina
the liquid pipeline la tubería con fugas
con perforaciones esto quiere decir que
si bien entran muchas mujeres a la
carrera profesional y universitaria sólo
unas pocas logran llegar a los estratos
más altos
déjenme darles otras cifras pensemos en
las carreras que se conocen como usted
sería ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemática por sus siglas en inglés les
quiero contar que los economistas
estamos peor que el promedio de estas
carreras en términos de participación
femenina ustedes ya se imaginarán que si
entramos a un laboratorio o entramos a
una sala de computadores no es fácil
encontrar mujeres las economistas somos
aún menos imaginémonos por ejemplo que
estamos recorriendo una facultad de
economía en eeuu o en inglaterra y vemos
pasar a los estudiantes a nuestro lado
vamos a ver que el triple de estudiantes
son hombres que las mujeres y después y
caminamos en esta facultad hacia las
oficinas de los profesores veremos que
los profesores hombres de economía son
diez veces más que las mujeres
profesoras también les puedo contar que
estas profesoras tienen más dificultad
para publicar en las revistas
especializadas y que los estudiantes que
acaban
de ver en los pasillos las evalúan con
mayor severidad para el mismo nivel de
aprendizaje que a sus colegas hombres
por lo tanto tenemos un problema es una
muy baja representación pero porque
debería importarnos por al menos dos
razones primero es una carrera rentable
con futuro es una carrera que tiene
impacto en la sociedad y el hecho de que
las mujeres participemos menos agrava
las diferencias entre hombres y mujeres
la segunda razón es que afecta la forma
en que la sociedad organiza su
estructura diseña sus políticas públicas
los economistas somos una carrera que
tenemos la oportunidad a veces más que
otras de participar en esta formación de
estructuras de participar en el diseño
de estas políticas ocupamos cargos en
ministerios gobiernos parlamentos
empresas nacionales e internacionales en
directorios de empresas chicas grandes
desde allí podemos moldear la sociedad y
si éste moldear la sociedad lo hace
solamente un grupo
perdiendo una parte importante de la
diversidad y además estas políticas
públicas afectan a la sociedad en su
conjunto no sólo a quienes diseñan las
políticas pero es verdad que las mujeres
tenemos intereses distintos de los
hombres los estudios indican que las
mujeres economistas se dedican con mayor
frecuencia a los estudios aplicados y
que hay temas que abordan también con
mayor frecuencia familia salud educación
mercado laboral y por supuesto los temas
de género esta baja participación por lo
tanto hace que tengamos sesgos en los
temas que están sobre el tapete en las
prioridades que asignamos y en la forma
en que los resolvemos por lo tanto
resulta necesario esencial que podamos
hablar porque se genera esta baja
participación y para hacer esto lo
primero que tenemos que preguntarnos es
de quién son los hijos
los hijos no son de las madres los hijos
son de las madres de los padres y de la
sociedad la sociedad como un todo no
puede tomar como una elección pero la
procreación mi madre es bióloga me lo
enseñó súper claramente la así la
sociedad no por crea no se sostiene en
el tiempo por lo tanto es posible que
algunas mujeres decidan tener más o
menos hijos o no tener ninguno pero la
tasa de natalidad en la sociedad tiene
que hacer un factor fundamental no es
una elección si a esto agregamos que
esta sociedad tiene que sostenerse tiene
que comer la verdad es que la mayoría de
estos seres humanos que estamos en la
sociedad tenemos que trabajar y tenemos
que procrear entonces conversemos
también de la participación de las
mujeres en el mercado laboral y aquí
aparece una típica frase de economista
para mejorar la participación de las
mujeres en el mercado laboral es
necesario repartir de forma más
equitativa el costo de tener hijos
este concepto de costo a mí me preocupa
profundamente
quiere decir esto que si yo estoy
cuidando a un hijo una hija enferma
estoy pagando el costo de tenerlo quiere
decir que si le ayudo con su tarea estoy
pagando el costo de tenerlo yo creo que
esta misión está profundamente
equivocada no puede ser un costo ayudar
a cuidar a acompañar a alguien un costo
desde los conceptos de economía es algo
que se paga que se sacrifica que
desaparece para que aparezca un producto
quiere decir entonces que este amor este
cuidado que ponemos en la familia
desaparece yo pienso todo lo contrario
no sólo no desaparece sino que afecta
profundamente a las personas que lo
vivencia ya la sociedad en su conjunto
no desaparece sino que construye
esta forma de pensar en la inequidad en
que se reparte el impacto de la
procreación tiene implicancias en las
estructuras de incentivos que afectan la
vida de los economistas pensemos por
ejemplo en las profesoras en la academia
una de las formas de evaluarlas es a
través del número de publicaciones que
hacen en revistas especializadas durante
un periodo de años
normalmente cuando una mujer tiene un
hijo se le entrega un receso en este
proceso la investigación que requieren
estos artículos es un proceso de impulso
sostenido requiere tiempo requiere
trabajo colectivo y por lo tanto se
entregan recesos respecto del prenatal y
del posnatal pero si nosotros nos
podemos imaginar bien que un embarazo
puede afectar tu productividad y también
la reinserción con un hijo pequeño lo
que nos damos cuenta es que estos
recesos no son suficientes y son tienen
un efecto que es
refleja inequidad respecto de cómo la
mujer en la familia y respecto de los
otros profesores recibe este impacto de
la procreación
lo que además vemos es que este impacto
se refleja en otros momentos de la vida
profesional en el caso de las mujeres
economistas estos impactos hacen que por
cada cinco hombres que logran avanzar al
profesor de planta por haber cumplido
con estos requisitos sólo cuatro mujeres
logran hacerlo
si además pensamos en una licencia
médica por ejemplo nos damos cuenta que
no es fácil llevar a un niño al médico
no sólo por la situación de dolor y de
estrés que tenemos sino porque el médico
nos va a hacer preguntas difíciles a qué
hora le empezó la fiebre que comió ayer
ha tenido algún cambio de comportamiento
en los últimos días si no acompañamos al
hijo a la hija en el proceso de los
síntomas es imposible que vayamos al
médico con ella y por lo tanto en la
forma que nuestras familias están
organizadas resulta ser que la madre
pasa a ser indispensable es decir en el
papel dice los padres pueden tomar la
responsabilidad de una licencia médica
pero en la práctica no son capaces de
responder estas preguntas porque la
forma en que se organizó la familia no
lo permite
esto significa que nuestras familias
tienen que organizarse de manera
distinta no cuando los niños se enferman
sino de manera cotidiana todo el tiempo
poniendo un esfuerzo sostenido en esto
es decir tenemos que cambiar las
estructuras de incentivos y nuestra
cotidianidad necesariamente pero estos
problemas aparecen cuando estamos
hablando de profesión yo les contaba
también de algunas cifras que dicen que
las mujeres eligen poco estudiar
economía
cifras recientes indican que no sólo
somos pocas quienes elegimos estudiar
economía sino que tampoco este número ha
variado desde el cambio de siglo tuvo su
peak en los años 90
es decir el panorama que les acabo de
pintar podría incluso empeorar si le
preguntamos a un estudiante cómo se
imagina a un economista probablemente se
imagina un hombre con una corbata
hablando de la última cifra de inflación
en algo que es bastante complicada no se
les entiende mucho estos economistas
entonces un hombre de corbata que hablan
complicado es muy difícil para una joven
identificarse con ese formato
además si les preguntamos a los
estudiantes en las encuestas al momento
de elegir en la universidad cuáles son
los conceptos que se asocian a la
carrera de economía las respuestas son
las siguientes 1
dos mercados oferta y demanda escasez
mucho más atrás aparecen otros conceptos
tales como pobreza políticas públicas
empleos salarios desigualdad
por lo tanto es muy difícil para ellos
para estos jóvenes pensar realistamente
en ser economistas además tenemos pocas
referentes mujeres y si además los
ponemos al día en este diagnóstico que
les acabo de ser la verdad es que hay
que ser bastante temeraria para entrar
en esta tubería llena de filtraciones
nosotros pensamos en lo que queremos ser
no solamente cuando entramos a la
universidad nos imaginamos por ejemplo
ser astronauta físico cantante
economista en la casa todavía me siguen
haciendo bromas porque yo cuando chica
decía que de grande quería ser turista
termine siendo economista podemos elegir
libremente si a nosotros a nuestros
niños no les damos estos referentes es
muy difícil que decidan y además
aparecen los estereotipos
no voy a hablar
de los vestiditos rosados
no voy a hablar tampoco de las joyas de
juguete
no voy a hablar de las mujeres y las
matemáticas aunque acá en realidad me
acuerdo de que los años 90 había una
versión parlante de esta muñeca rubia
alta que tenía incorporada la siguiente
frase
la clase de matemática de hoy estaba muy
difícil
quiero hablar de lo cotidiano mejor no
de estas cosas en lo cotidiano tenemos
muchas cosas que cambiar tenemos en el
lenguaje incorporada formas que no
valoran la diversidad déjenme contarles
una experiencia
hay una comisión en la que me interesaba
mucho participar
suene el teléfono y es el presidente de
la comisión que me invita
alejandra queremos que integre nuestro
equipo excelente de giro fantástico pero
después escuché lo siguiente
lo que pasa es que queremos darle un
poco de diversidad
para dar un poco de diversidad queremos
una mujer
a cualquiera
entonces este llamado para mí fue
realmente muy fuerte
no estamos en el tiempo de dar un poco
de diversidad no estamos en el tiempo de
de hacer gestos políticos hacia las
minorías
las mujeres no somos minoría y aunque lo
fuéramos estamos en un momento en que la
sociedad necesita valorar la diversidad
con razón somos pocas economistas y
entonces cómo podemos cambiarlo quiero
proponerles tres cambios
el primero tenemos que cambiar las
estructuras de incentivos profesionales
para reparar está esta tubería con
filtraciones no hablar más de repartir
costos de tener hijos sino hablar de la
responsabilidad compartida de la
procreación y la formación de una
sociedad mejor segundo necesitamos
mostrar referentes reales factibles a
nuestros jóvenes y niños para que puedan
elegir de verdad esta profesión y esto
significa sacar los estereotipos de lo
que significa ser economista y reconocer
la potencia que tiene esta carrera para
transformar la sociedad y a la vez
mostrar referentes hombres y mujeres y
como estamos en deuda con las segundas
lo que tenemos que hacer es
comprometernos hoy día
a visibilizar lo que las economistas
estamos haciendo en este ámbito tercero
tenemos que superar los estereotipos los
estereotipos tenemos que cambiar
fuertemente hoy día ahora con urgencia
nuestra vida cotidiana para que los
niños puedan elegir libremente quiénes
quieren ser y cómo hacerlo enfocar su
educación en la persona en personas
inteligentes relacionales y no en
figuras celestes o rosadas
como se dan cuenta en realidad no estoy
hablando de mujeres ni menos de
economistas estoy hablando de una
sociedad que tiene que dar un paso
adelante en la calidad en que nos
relacionamos con la diversidad
nosotros los economistas hablamos
frecuentemente de valor recursos riqueza
la diversidad es parte de la función de
producción de la sociedad del bienestar
esto significa que si no ves la
diferencia si no ves la diversidad si no
la incorpora en tu lenguaje en lo
cotidiano no solamente estás dejando de
ganar estamos perdiendo fuertemente
la diversidad es riqueza
[Aplausos]